public sénat en partenariat avec afp
les échos radio classique présente bien
laurent sénateur secrétaire nationale du
parti communiste français est l'invité
de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france presse avec les échos et
avec radio classique et bien sûr vous
répondrez à trois grandes questions que
viendront vous posez lucile malandain
olivier armand et mickaël szames s1 les
communistes vont ils se réconcilier avec
jean luc mélenchon jusqu'à former un
groupe commun d'opposition de gauche
emmanuel macron à l'assemblée où les
élus d'ailleurs de la france un insoumis
vous avez vu ça on fait une entrée
remarquée en pack
aujourd'hui deux contestez-vous la
légitimité des manuels macron pour
réformer notamment la loi travail enfin
troisième question l'état d'urgence dans
le droit commun c'est une nécessité a
martelé hier le ministre de l'intérieur
sur les champs elysées est ce également
votre avis pire le rang mais une toute
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
après le second tour des législatives
vont nous annoncer un simple remaniement
technique mais la sphère s'avère
beaucoup plus complexe exfiltration vers
l'assemblée de richard ferrand départ de
sylvie goulard d'autres peut-être du
modem comme elle on ne sait pas encore s
que vous jugez ce soir que le
gouvernement est dans la tourmente
ça fait ça fait effectivement étrange
alors que le gouvernement démarre à
peine qui va être formé les
personnalités que vous citez sont des
poids lourds du gouvernement donc ça
n'est pas anodin le sort qui est réservé
à richard ferron est quand même assez
curieux parce qu'on laisse fillon l'ex
filtre du gouvernement pour des affaires
et ont le même président du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale alors que le
parlement va entamer sa va commencer au
sénat d'ailleurs la discussion sur la
loi de moralisation enfin elle s'appelle
plus comme ça la loi pour retrouver
confiance dans l'action publique
donc tout ça effectivement état c est
assez étrange étrange étrange étrange
également que françois bayrou reste au
gouvernement pour défendre cette loi
alors que sa collègue du modem comme lui
également cités dans l'enquêté sur les
assistants parlementaires est payé par
papa par le parlement européen et sur la
sphère des assistants parlementaires
européens à l'ailé gauche en revanche
son courroux sait pas très bien
d'ailleurs si finalement ils vont être
mis en cause ou pas les procédures sont
assez longues au parlement européen ce
qui ce qui est effectivement une enquête
de la gt qui effectivement perturbant
c'est que on a des ministres qui vont
être au front sur la question de la
moralisation de la vie publique qui sont
eux mêmes concernés
ça renforce des propositions que nous
allons porter d'ailleurs nous dans le
débat parlementaire pour améliorer
encore les dispositions transparence les
dispositions de prévention des conflits
d'intérêts voilà surtout ça il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire débat
parlementaire nous permettra de faire
adopter des propositions plus audacieuse
que celle que qui figure pour le moment
dans l'accord dans le projet à bien vers
le moment vous dites
étrange perturbant mais répondez moi
est-ce que vous demander le départ de
françois bayrou et de marielle de sarnez
qui sont tous les deux
cité dont j'ai parlé à faire du
gouvernement j'ai pas de raison de
demander le départ leur françois bayroux
par exemple du gouvernement est ce que
vous trouvez néanmoins que la situation
devient gênante pour emmanuel macron ou
alors est-ce que vous lui accorder un
crédit supplémentaire ou un crédit tout
court d'ailleurs non il essaie des
choses je pense depuis le début que
contrairement à ce qu'on annonce cette
majorité de n'est pas une majorité de
vrai renouveau politique et l est et
tous les élus qu'on nous présente comme
venant de la société civile tout ça en
vérité sont très liés sont très liés au
mieux aux milieux économiques au milieu
aux milieux dirigeants du pays déjà donc
bien qu'ils pensaient tout ça mais je
pense en général à la majorité des
manuels macro je pense qu'on va
découvrir progressivement qu'on est très
très loin du renouveau politique
annoncée et je pense que ça ça remettra
les choses à leur juste place
il y aurait des choses plus profondes à
faire pour renouveler la représentation
politique à propos de renouvellement est
par exemple la proportionnelle d'accord
ce que c'est un débat gras reviendra
d'ailleurs par le premier ministre
lui-même d'ailleurs qui vient de la
droite parce que vous dénoncez un
renouvellement en trompe l'oeil et le
premier ministre philippe a annoncé que
sa volonté entre les quatre d'élargir
encore plus le gouvernement d'ouvrir
vers la droite
comment est-ce que vous jugez cette
intention alors qu'on ne connaît pas
encore mais elle est personnelle m'aide
et l'air tout savoir et tout ça ne me
surprend pas parce que on sait depuis le
départ qu'une partie des députés de
droite et d'ailleurs ils viennent de
constituer un groupe aujourd'hui
mais quand vont ils vont appuyer
le gouvernement que même ceux qui ne
font pas partie de ce groupe vont très
probablement voter très souvent les
textes du du gouvernement donc on voit
bien que on a une orientation globale du
gouvernement qui va s'affirmer comme
vous lisez bien droit oui qui va très
clairement penché à droite 3 4 ap à
droite
à bâle ça c'est clair on écoute et on
met pas un premier ministre de droite
aux manettes un ministre de l'économie
de droite en place un ministre du budget
de droite
si c'est pour mener une politique qui
n'a rien à voir avec les avec les
conceptions de la droite
donc cette tout ça je crois va
s'éclaircir au fur et à mesure et nous
promet encore beaucoup de beaucoup de
débats politiques je pense que tout ça
n'est pas stabilisée dakar toute
dernière question avant de voir la suite
le modem n'est pas le seul parti
concerné par les assistants
parlementaires et leur emploi dans
d'autres fonctions que au service des
assemblées de strasbourg ou de paris
vous diriger un parti
est ce que le cumul de fonctions des
assistants parlementaires au service
partielle du parti existe aussi ou non
mais ce n'est pas ça la question il as
et les graisses des noms mais non parce
que il ya un débat derrière ça les
assistants parlementaires
j'ai comme tout le monde et insistants
parlementaire et travailler travail
parlementaire travaille à amo ils sont
payés pour ça il m'a 6 dont le travail
parlementaire et nous en avons besoin
sans les assistants parlementaires nous
il fallait ça pour rire c mais certains
d'entre eux peuvent être dans leurs
dents lors des militants politiques
aussi kiki qui participent à l'activité
de leur parti c'est pas des gens
étrangers à la vie politique certains ne
le sont pas certains les hackers tout ça
on est citoyen qui ont aussi des droits
de participer à la bipolarité trail être
au service d'un parti comme ça n'a rien
payé par un parlement sans autre chose
oui mais il faudrait rentrer dans le
détail de ce que c'est que le travail
d'un parlementaire comme quand vous
estimez d'affaires algéro les textes
mais je mène aussi beaucoup de travail
politique dans le pays
je parcours le pays comme parlementaire
comme sénateur pour aller porter une
parole politique sur les textes dont je
m'occupe mais pas seulement dans les
textes
j'ai une fonction qui est plus large que
seulement parfaitement dans la légalité
mais bien sûr d'accord la suite tout de
suite avec lucile malandain notre
consoeur de la fp qui nous rejoint
l'épreuve de vérité un déclic
bonsoir lucie l'heure vous avez une
question la question à poser à pierre
laurent
bonjour les communistes vont t'il alors
se réconcilier avec jean luc mélenchon
au point de former un groupe commun
l'assemblée nationale d'opposition à la
politique
écoutez cette discussion elle va être
débattu par les par les députés
communistes demain je crois que les
députés de la france a soumis se sont
réunis aujourd'hui les députés
communistes ils sont onze vont se réunir
demain et c'est eux qui vont prendre qui
vont prendre cette décision
ce qui est certain c'est que dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes donc
à un parlement archi dominé par macro
nous allons être convergents dans mon
travail sur beaucoup de choses dont qui
serait il faut trouver des formes de
travail commune est ce que ça pourra
aller jusqu'au groupe comment c'est les
députés qui vont en discuter et qui vont
après en discuter entre les députés de
la france insoumise et des députés
commune quel est votre avis vous moi la
disposition au travail qui sera la
meilleure la plus efficace pour faire du
commun et qui permettent à chacune des
sensibilités de pouvoir de pouvoir
s'exprimer
voilà sera la meilleure fodil faut 10
privée mais en plus je sais c'est
sérieux ce que je vais vous dire je
pense qu'effectivement les députés moi
je suis sous ceux de sa ici dans le
groupe a au sénat quand on a ces
questions à discuter son voilà prennent
leurs responsabilités par les mauves ont
parlé entre eux et vont chercher je vous
dis la meilleure disposition de
possibles ça ne va pas faire dit
nous avons beaucoup de choses je le
répète à féron comment ça ne va pas
faire disparaître du jour au lendemain
les débats que nous avons eus pour
l'élection présidentielle et que nous
aurons peut-être demain avec la france
sera soumise
alors on va écouter jean luc mélenchon
il ya quelques instants parce que il
parle de vos échanges
après les mots très durs que vous avez
changé d'ailleurs sur un ton plutôt
apaisée et on va parler avec eux c'est
tout le monde est de bonne foi
une fois qu'on aura percé les abcès qui
sont nombreux on envisage rage il ya pas
trop de difficulté toute façon on va
être unis dans combat jeu je connais sa
hache de siéger pendant des années ou
bien assis à côté du groupe communiste
parce que moi même j'étais socialiste au
sénat au bien avec les communistes
quand j'ai été sénateur fribourgeois on
a toujours combattu ensemble bois
reprendra pas les mêmes méthodes on n'a
pas les mêmes sensibilités tout le monde
le sait mais bon ne sommes pas
communiste au sens nous sommes pas
membres du parti communiste français ça
sert à rien de nous d'essayer de nous
annexer ça sert à rien mais je crois que
ça devrait se passer simplement alors
pas d'injection pas l'annexion non il y
aura pas d'affection mais je pense que
si tout le monde est dans un état
d'esprit à la fois comme je les dis de
faire du commun et de de se respecter
tels que nous sommes
il devrait y avoir des solutions on a
bien vu ou lu tion comme une autre donc
la dernière année qui est passée que
justement les plaies ont été ouvertes
est réouverte que les choses ne se sont
pas bien passées et que vous m nous on
aime papa venu avec jean luc mélenchon à
faire du commun justement y compris en
le soutenant d'ailleurs à la dans sa
candidature à la présidentielle
qu'est-ce qu'il ferait que là les choses
auraient changé mais finalement est
d'ailleurs jean-luc mélenchon le dit lui
même sur sur un certain nombre de
conceptions nous ne fonctionnons pas
pareil compris peut-être même dans le
travail parlementaire et le la relation
au travail démocratique bon voilà tout
ça mais en quoi mais en quoi est ce que
c'est un problème que les forces les 29
députés venus de différentes formations
est ce qu'il ya des députés de la france
est soumise il ya des députés
communistes
il ya aussi quelques députés qui
viennent d'autres d'autres formations ou
des personnalités comme françois ruffin
donc je pense que il va falloir vivre
avec cette diversité là et vivre
intelligemment mais je le répète ça ne
fera pas disparaître tous les débats
existent
il ya des différences mais ce qui est
certain c'est que sur l'essentiel on le
voit bien
face aux projets qui vont nous arriver
par exemple des mois de juillet nous
nous allons faire nous allons faire
front commun
c'est c'est probable enfin ce alors là
par contre ce serait une énorme surprise
si ce n'était pas le cas donc mais je
pense que nous avons en commun ou dans
deux groupes séparés
vous ferez fonds communs oui il faut
faire front commun c'est ça l'essentiel
il faut trouver la bonne méthode pour le
faire on voit là on permettant à chacun
d'exprimer et moi je ne veux pas prendre
parti dans cette discussion vous êtes le
chef du oui mais je pense que les
députés
je connais bien les routes glissantes et
lisez bien les 11 députés
non il vous dit qu'ils sont des visées
je ne crois pas ce sont des ce sont des
personnalités fortes je les connais bien
et ils ont envie de décider ça ressemble
d'ailleurs je voulais laisser merci de
sao tomé marie george buffet est une
communiste à part entière ça c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
elle a même été inscrits à ses électeurs
les électeurs en général et de la france
un sommier et du parti communiste ne
comprendraient pas qu'il n'y a pas de
groupe comme un non mais c'est ce que je
dis je pense qu'effectivement nos
électeurs ne comprendraient pas qu'on
conçoit pas ensemble dans la riposte
emmanuel macron il faut être ensemble
dans la riposte à emmanuel macron il
faut être vraiment le même bannière
pouvait reposer la question du quoi
comme je vais laisser comme je vais
laisser les députés communistes demain à
discuter de ça entre eux je vais quand
même une pose des conditions quand même
lui posa sa femme avec ambition forte
ces disciplines date matin puis c'est
lui qui veut présider le groupe résident
avant d'accepter ou pas ben justement ça
fait si on veut discuter il faut il faut
il faut pouvoir pour pouvoir discuter ça
fait partie des choses à discuter on
peut pas si ici aussi on nous dit on va
discuter tout le monde voit la jolie
avait apaisé dans ce qu'il disait tout à
l'heure
bon donc il faut pouvoir discuter
tranquillement dès qu'il ya quand même
vous avez comble ce passif terrible il a
eu des mots de terribles il ya qualité a
rapporté de rentrer dans un sms je suis
désolé je vais
il avait dit
le ps il avait comparé sa à la mort et
au nez vous pouvez oublier ça
aujourd'hui vous savez il y à une
majorité écrasante des manuels moi la
seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est ça il
ya une majorité écrasante des manuels
macro nous sommes avec vingt députés
certains de la france a soumises
d'autres communiste avec d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus de communistes que
certains nous avaient nous avait annoncé
on nous avait un peu rayé de la carte un
peu vite quand même et bien aujourd'hui
ils vont porter ses députés la voix de
millions et de millions de personnes
et d'ailleurs ils sont trop faiblement
représentés cesser ses électeurs à cause
des modes de scrutin
donc ils ont une responsabilité en
portant sans faiblement représentés
parce que oui il ya eu beaucoup
d'abstention aussi quand même un nom
mais aussi parce que notamment pour tous
les âges
parce que l'effet du scrutin auprès de
ghost et on aura un scrutin à la
proportionnelle même qu'ils ne diraient
que 50% des députés à la proportionnelle
il y aurait 84 députés communistes et
insoumis à l'assemblée nationale il y en
a 29
donc on voit la déformation que crée la
représentation politique elle est énorme
donc je pense que cette responsabilité
il faut l'assumer je le répète ne fait
pas disparaître les débats chacun va
vouloir être respectée tel qu'il est
c'est bien normal et il peut y avoir ni
compris dans un groupe comme ça il y en
a tous les jours dans le groupe auquel
je participe et jean luc mélenchon
connaît très bien lui qui a été
parlementaire il ya toujours dans des
groupes des débats sur la manière dont
on se positionne par rapport à telle ou
telle échéance il faut pouvoir les
députés ont besoin de cette liberté
d'agir si vous êtes de dialogue avec
leurs électeurs si vous êtes du point de
vue idéologique et programmatique
d'accord sur l'essentiel avec jean luc
mélenchon pardon il y a des points sur
lequel il y à des ruptures on pense à la
sortie du nucléaire l'europe et ses
combos coup vous rabâche régulièrement
est ce que justement
sur ces points là ce serait important
d'avoir un groupe indépendant et
autonome pour les passer ce que je dis
quelle que soit la configuration qu'on
trouve il faut bien il faut bien que
cette diversité quand elles existent
parce que sur beaucoup de questions
ce sera convergent elles puissent aussi
trouver de l'espace paul bakker dans les
virages que ça correspond aussi à des
choses qu'on dit les électeurs
voilà ce qu'est donc été de vote
que vous exigez voilà que jean luc
mélenchon au contraire de présidence
mais la liberté
je ne comprend pas toujours ce débat
parce que la liberté de vote c'est pas
tout le monde fait tout et n'importe
quoi à nous aussi on a envie de
cohérence politique
on est dans un groupe et en général dans
les groupes dans lesquels on est onze
cherche à avoir des positions communes
ont fait passer pas chacun fait 5e sinon
évidemment ça n'a pas de sens
donc bien sûr la cohérence politique
mais je rappelle par contre que le
mandat impératif c'est
anticonstitutionnel nous sommes
redevenus sommes comptables devant des
électeurs à la france sa saison et ne
reconnaît assez facilement il disait ça
c'est bien
selecta et bien c'est tous ces points là
c'est tout cette menace qui je pose
seront l'objet d'une discussion pourra
vérifier
on a vu lité de travail en commun ou pas
on a vu vos différences en tous les cas
d' approche
il a dit tu es un peu arrogant nom
n'avait pas trouvé aujourd'hui jean-luc
mélenchon quand il est arrivé à
l'assemblée en disant que j'étais dans
un séminaire de mad direction de lille
a10 pour discuter de l'avenir j'ai pas
vu les y force d'expliquer le code du
travail à tous les élus de la république
en marche il
il les voit un peu comme des gens
ignorants et notamment il s'en est pris
au mathématicien cédric villani qui est
qu'il lui ait répondu à d'ailleurs assez
vertement sur twitter qu'est ce que vous
pensez est-ce que je vais partir
qu'est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que je
vais missionner de la ligue 2 cédric
villani way
je ne suis pas je les côtoyer la
campagne municipale à paris quand on
saute les listes il a mis des contrats
de travail
franchement je ne pense pas que cédric
villani soit notre première notre
premier adversaire justement est-ce que
c'était une erreur un peu de jean luc
mélenchon d'avoir fait ça comme premier
mais moi je vais pas je vais pas
commenter toutes les déclarations où
tous les mots de passe à une note
jean-luc mélenchon l'autre chose qui
pourrait pas ce que vous avez une
provocation notamment à votre endroit
jean luc mélenchon devenant député au
parlement français va devoir évidemment
quitter le parlement européen
la deuxième personne sur la liste qui
devrait prendre sa place marie pierre
vieu et membre de la direction du parti
communiste mais jean-luc mélenchon a dit
très clairement qu'il souhaitait se
faire remplacer enfin que le suppléant
soit manuelle bompard qui était son
directeur de campagne
est-ce que ça ça fait partie du jeu
justement aussi des éléments qui
négocient d'abord je vois pas lire le
rapport avec la avec la question
président sur la vie du groupe mais en
plus il ya une logique on a fait une
liste commune à allah dans une liste
proportionnelle donc il ya une règle
lundi de son mandat c'est le suivant qui
qu'il remplace donc marie pierre vieu
qui a mené la campagne en deuxième de
liste aux côtés de jean luc mélenchon
d'ailleurs et qui avait beaucoup
travaillé à son élection dans la grande
circonscription du sud-ouest je pense
qui est très implanté dans la région qui
a conduit qui a été très active elle
conduisait pas mais elle a été très
active dans la conduite de la liste
front gauche et nouveau monde dans les
élections régionales gros sujet est
totalement légitime d'accord un point de
friction à la dernière question vous
avez cité françois pour moi j'attends un
point de fric travail là il ya une
différence d'interprétation
vous avez cité françois ruffin le
réalisateur est lui dedans dans la somme
il veut se payer au smic
est ce que vous estimez que c'est une
bonne mesure qu'il s'applique à lui-même
puisqu'il faudrait donc l'appliquer à
tous les élus communistes et de la
france a soumis
nous on a un principe qui est un peu
différent que celui là mais j'ai eu un
jeu je comprends je comprends ce qu'il
dit c'est que bon général les gens quand
ils deviennent parlementaire on a une
profession métier était ouvrier était
professeur était on essaye que leurs
conditions de vie ne se dégradent pas au
moment où ils deviennent parlementaire
vous savez quand on a un principe on
reverse une partie des indemnités en
partie pour le fonctionnement collective
du groupe ou du parti et puis on est
sans garde des revenus qui sont
conformes à ce qu'on avait précédemment
professionnellement pour pouvoir ensuite
voilà retourner dans la vie
professionnelle quand on arrête le
mandat dans des conditions qui est ça
nous protège justement de
l'enrichissement personnel ou du
sentiment que on va vivre mieux parce
qu'on a une indemnité parlementaire
importante donc nous on s'applique ce
principe là alors ça conduit des c'est
pas toujours exactement la même somme
selon les personnes merci beaucoup mais
c'est la suite de l'épreuve de vérité
avec olivier armor des échos qui ne
rejoint maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir olivier soirée bienvenue parmi
nous merci pour cette première pour vous
alors vous avez une question soir pierre
laurent au soir emmanuel macron a
remporté largement la présidentielle il
a remporté largement avec son mouvement
les élections législatives et malgré une
abstention record
il bénéficie encore d'une dynamique
assez vive contestez-vous encore sa
légitimité à réformer donc je n'ai pas à
contester la légitimité des manuels
macro à mais ça ne m'empêchera pas de
jouer de jouer mon rôle d'opposant au
rôle politique d'opposants à cette
politique donc reconnaître sa légitimité
c'est ne pas ça n'a rien à voir avec
s'effacer devant les propositions des
balles vaincrons parce que sinon c'est
pas la peine d'élire un parlement
mais là c'est déjà important ce que vous
dites parce qu'il ya eu des procès en
légitimité au soir du second tour
il ya un énorme problème de légitimité
mais qui par légitimité au sens où il ne
devrait pas être président de la
république il a été élu mais par contre
il y a un sérieux problème c'est que
d'élection en élection alors c'est pas
vrai de l'élection présidentielle mais
par exemple pour les élections
législatives
le taux de participation baisse la
présidentialisation excessive conduit à
ça dévalorise les élections et donc on a
un problème démocratique parce
qu'effectivement élire par exemple
l'assemblée nationale du pays avec moins
de la moitié des français
on connaissait ça dans d'autres grandes
démocraties comme les etats-unis ou
l'autre mais pas en france donc ça c'est
un affaissement démocratique grave et on
ne peut pas rester les bras croisés
devant ça et puis dire bon bah peu
importe
et si demain ils sont élus avec 25% des
électeurs tout le monde va dire ben
c'est la même chose non et il ya un très
grave problème qui devrait obliger à
toucher au régime présidentiel et à
conduire des réformes institutionnelles
sur les réformes en tous les cas avec
maintenant un pouvoir légitime pour les
engager justement parce que vous
souhaitez donc ne pas rester
les bras croisés c'est ce que vous
expliquez vous voulez donc être dans
l'opposition vous allez lui laisser
combien de temps à emmanuel macron
sachant que par exemple sur la réforme
du travail
il souhaite agir vite fort par
ordonnance dès l'été canon on va pas lui
laisser tomber c'est lui qui nous on
laisse pas parce que il
il va proposer aux parlementaires de
voter la loi d'habilitation
d'habilitation des ordonnances alors
même que les discussions avec les
syndicats ne sont pas terminées donc en
gros on va nous votons va nous demander
de voter une loi d'habilitation des
ordonnances sans connaître le contenu on
connaîtra vaguement les têtes de
chapitre puisque c'est à ça que va
servir la loi d'habilitation
donc c'est lui qui a un problème avec le
temps il est dispersé au lieu de donner
au parlement les moyens de discuter
sérieusement des projets de l'est de
pouvoir les étudier en toute
transparence de pouvoir nous même en
parler avec les organisations syndicales
parce qu'il n'ya pas que le gouvernement
quel droit de parler avec les
organisations syndicales
nous sommes des représentants des
électeurs nous avons droit aussi nous
faire notre opinion et bien le
gouvernement veut nous priver de ce
temps là et nous priver de ce pouvoir là
donc nous nous allons avant même de
parler du contenu nous nous exprimerons
contre le recours même odeur devrait on
écoute le premier ministre qui précise
et justement ce matin à la méthode la
concertation au programme dit il et
comme les ordonnances il y aura une
discussion parlementaire en juillet à
l'assemblée sur une loi d'habilitation
cette loi d'habilitation
on va la présenter à l'assemblée pour
que le parlement nous autorise à écrire
par ordonnance les modifications dans le
gros du travail que nous voulons porter
mais cette loi d'habilitation sera
discuté à l'assemblée
le contenu des ordonnances sera discuté
avec les organisations syndicales nous
sortiront avant la fin de l'été je ne
veux pas présenter les résultats non
mais voilà donc il va sûrement ça fait
plus d'un mois
ça a commencé ça fait plus d'un mois on
nous parle de la concertation qu'on ne
me s'adresser mais où on sait toujours
rien quand il ya des informations qui
sont parues dans la presse sur des
textes provisoire la ministre a même
menacé de porter plainte contre certains
qui auraient fait fuiter ces textes donc
comment est-ce qu'on va disposer nous
d'un minimum d'informations pour se
prononcer au parlement
en vérité parce que c'est ça les
ordonnances on nous demande de nous
dessaisir du pouvoir de légiférer qui
appartient au parlement au profit de
l'exécutif donc c'était une procédure
contestable les ordonnances on nous dit
qu'il allait très vite après ménages à
haute tension quand même un oui d'accord
c'est prévu dans la constitution mais
rien n'oblige à utiliser il ya beaucoup
de choses dans la constitution qui pose
des problèmes
on l'a vu avec le 49 3 et avec d'autres
dispositions qui sont utilisés qu'ils
ont constitutionnel en soignant il y
avait une reco en 1980 pour les
bienvenus ceux ci reconnaissait aux
communistes une certaine constance sur
la matière nous avons toujours dénoncé
ces articles qui donne des pouvoirs
exceptionnels au président de la
république mais pierre l'an le fait
justement qu emmanuel macron est annoncé
clairement pendant la campagne
présidentielle qu'il utiliserait ses
ordonnances pour la loi et qu'il le
ferait rapidement et qu'il a tout de
même été élu est ce que ça lui confère
pas quelque part une légitimité c'est
une question oui mais je crois que ça ne
ça n'autorise pas à priver parlement son
pouvoir et je pense que nous nous
battrons pour faire respecter pour faire
respecter les droits du parlement et
pour faire la clarté sur le contenu
parce que vous lille les gens ont voté
en connaissance de cause dans ils
entendent un discours général dans
lequel on leur dit on va réformer ça va
être plus moderne ça va être formidable
ça va créer des emplois
personne ne prouve j'avais rien de tout
ça c'est qu'au moment du cic on nous a
dit on va donner 40 milliards aux
entreprises ça va créer plein d'emplois
toutes les études montrent que ça n'a
pas été vrai mais ça continue donc là
nous non non par exemple que est ce que
les mesures qui figureront dans les
ordonnances vont être évalués vous savez
quand on vote un projet de loi il ya une
étude d'impact dans ce projet de loi qui
dit voilà ce que ça pourrait produire
est ce que les dispositions qui sont
contenus dans les ordonnances seront
évalués non elles ne le seront pas il
n'aura pas d'étude d'impact puisque le
gouvernement le parlement ne va pas
pouvoir exercer son vin qu'il ya un
grave problème de méthode alors juste
une contenu évidemment parce que là on
parle pas du contenu mais il ya beaucoup
de choses très inquiétant donc ce que le
gouvernement au visage le faire
engranger effectivement au fil des jeux
on va découvrir au mois d'août hongrois
parce que le gouvernement va recevoir
des syndicats sans vraiment leur donner
la vérité des prix jusqu'à la fin du
mois de juillet pendant ce temps là nous
on sera obligé de voter la loi
d'habilitation des ordonnances et ils
vont publier le texte au mois d'août
parce que c'est quand même vers ça qu'on
se dirige alors justement genre la
transparence démocratique justement
pierlot on va parler un peu du contenu
l'une des mesures phares et qui est un
point de crispation justement entre ce
que veut le gouvernement est ce que
voudraient les syndicats c'est notamment
la volonté de faire passer les accords
d'entreprise devant les accords de
branche
est ce que vous nous dites
qu'aujourd'hui que vous soyez au
parlement avec la france a soumises ou
pas dans un bon parlementaire ou pas que
c'est vraiment le point sur lequel vous
ne lâcherait rien faire baisser le point
central parce que ce poids là c'est quoi
c'est l'ouverture au dumping social
généralisé sur toutes les questions là
de la durée du travail le ton travail la
nature des contrats etc
ça veut dire qu'une entreprise quelles
que soient les accords de branche
quelles que soient les la loi peut
déroger à sa dont son entreprise si on
ouvre la possibilité à ça et si on le
fait sur toutes les questions
importantes qui tiennent au contenu du
contrat de travail et aux conditions de
travail alors à ce moment-là ça veut
dire que la la concurrence par le mal
d'hommes ping social va se généraliser
entre entreprises françaises
les petites entreprises seront tirés
vers le bas parce que les donneurs
d'ordres vont s'en servir contre elle
les salariés vont être pris dans le
contrôle marteau et l'enclume et vont le
payer très cher donc nous nous sommes
résolument effectivement contre cette
disposition mais face à ces arguments
justement le gouvernement dit un peul
inverse ils disent que justement par
exemple une entreprise qui est en
difficulté peut justement avec des
accords d'entreprise être plus flexible
ne serait-ce qu sur un an atteint points
et de façon temporaire
vous répondez quoi et makelele quel est
le second n'a jamais fait la
démonstration qu'il y avait un lien
entre le code du travail et la création
d'emplois si on veut nous parler s'il
sujet c'est la lutte contre le chômage
et la création d'emplois nous nous
disons où sont les programmes de
création d'emplois où sont les
investissements qui vont permettre de
créer vraiment de l'emploi mais c'est
pas parce que vous allez flexibilise
encore au maximum les contrats de
travail elle est précarisé que ça va
créer de l'emploi
ça ne servira qu'à tirer vers le bas les
conditions sociales de ceux qui en ont
déjà
mais ça ne créera pas un emploi de plus
donc l'emploi c'est un autre sujet et
c'est celui-là qu'il faudrait vraiment
ouvrir le sujet numéro un devrait les
programmes d'investissement pour créer
non parce que vous ne faites pas fait
l'avocat évidemment dû peut-être de dia
pour vous mais d'un procès d'intention
emmanuel macron qui est très actif très
offensif par ailleurs sur le terrain
européen pour réformer le système des
travailleurs détachés pour défendre les
secteurs stratégiques en créant un
système de ben ayoub khan acte est ce
que là ce n'est pas une façon justement
j'ai lutté contre le dumping social
habitude de faire des liens bien réelle
en europe de faire des procès
d'intention hommage argumente et
j'attends qu'on oppose aux
démonstrations et aux arguments que nous
avançons des démonstration inverse pour
le moment on a face à nous des dogmes
idéologiques qui en vérité masquer le
fait qu'on va aller au devant des
exigences qui sont des exigences des
actionnaires des dirigeants
d'entreprises notamment les plus
importants on va travailler ça consiste
à tirer
oui bien sûr tout le monde le sait est
d'ailleurs pierre gattaz est ravi de ce
qui est en train de se passer et l'appui
et l'appui fortement aidé que le
gouvernement envisage même de renoncer à
tel ou tel petit bout de mesures c'est
là que pierre gattaz s'exprimer pour
dire à tel point que par exemple sur le
plafonnement des indemnités prud'homale
qui a été repoussé deux fois par le
parle dans le quinquennat précédent et
bien emmanuel macron veut remettre le
couvert et on sait que c'est le medef
qui pousse à sa très fortement le medef
bien que la loi était porté par le parti
socialiste tout de même vous savez que
le parti socialiste qui a porté cette
loi nous l'avons abondamment ont
combattu dans le précédent quinquennat
c'est effectivement mais alors il ya eu
dans des négociations
chacun met un peu des arguments dans ça
balance l'un des arguments également d'
emmanuel macron et j'aimerais qu'on
aborde ce sujet parce qu'il est très
important c'est le sujet de la formation
il promet un investissement de 15
milliards d'euros
est ce que vous êtes prêts à lâcher du
lest par exemple sur cette question des
branches professionnelles versus les
branches les accords d'entreprise si il
accepte d'être de de faire un plan de
formation plus efficace il emmenait en
eau ce qui est proposé
justement ne va pas dans ce sens là
écoutez nous la formation c'est un sujet
majeur
on a déposé au mois de janvier un projet
de loi sur le bureau du parlement pour
la création d'un système d'un nouveau
système d'emploi de formation d'une
sécurité d'emploi et de formation
nous notre proposition elle est beaucoup
plus ambitieuse que tout ça on propose
que les gens quand ils entrent sur le
marché du travail après leur période de
formation soient inscrits
automatiquement dans un service public
de l'emploi et qu'il puisse tout au long
de leur vie avec des revenus garantis
évolué entre emploi et formation est
plutôt que de dépenser de l'argent dans
des organismes de formation
professionnelle qui sont souvent pilotés
par le patronat pour des objectifs qui
n'ont pas grand chose à voir à voir avec
la formation tandis que les salariés ont
beaucoup de problèmes à avoir accès à
leurs droits à la formation
eh bien il faut créer un service public
de l'emploi et de la formation qui
permettrait de manière ambitieuse
justement d'éradiquer le chômage
donc nous si on veut ouvrir ce chantier
là nous nous en tiendrons pas aux
propositions gouvernementales nous avons
nous-mêmes beaugrand proposition
dernière question alors est ce que vous
réclamez comme jean luc mélenchon sur
cette réforme
loi travail un référendum écouter avant
de parler de référendum alors non on va
déjà mené même combat on sait qui va
être difficile parce que le gouvernement
le messie mais c'est une arme par milo
d'accord un peu on vous avez envie que
la visite revivre une séquence sociale
aussi éprouvante violente même que
l'heure de la loi elle conneries un don
mais j'ai jamais envie que de ça aussi
parce que parce que vous savez que pour
les salariés faire grève ou arrêter le
travail tout ça c'est jade est simple
mais si le gouvernement attaque durement
les conditions de vie des travailleurs
il faut qu'il se défend merci beaucoup
vive voix la troisième partie et
dernière partie de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant on va changer de sujet avec
mickaël zeze de public sénat qui nous
rejoint
[Musique]
concert michael bond soit michel
bronsard père laurent buffard vous
parlez de du terrorisme après l'action
qui a eu lieu hier sur les champs
elysées tentative d'attentât introduire
l'état d'urgence dans le droit commun
c'est ce qui a demandé
c'est ce que souhaite le ministre de
l'intérieur quel est votre avis sur la
question est ce vous allez dans le sens
du ministre de l'intérieur
non nous n'allons pas d'encenser ce
n'est pas un débat nouveau nous savons
que la menace est réelle sérieuse et on
le voit malheureusement en france et
dans d'autres pays
dans d'autres pays dans le monde donc
mais estimant pas cette menace nous
avons un débat sur la manière de la
combattre il ya un discours assez
contradictoires du gouvernement parce
que d'un côté il dit on va sortir de
l'état d'urgence
ça fait déjà trois fois qu'on nous le
promet mais en vérité on va pas vraiment
sortir tu qu'on va faire rentrer dans le
droit commun toutes les dispositions qui
a deux en or ce qui pose problème c'est
qu'il ya des dispositions qui kino qui
sont plus efficaces qui peuvent être
efficaces dans l'urgence mais qu'ils ne
sont pas forcément dans la durée de
restriction du pouvoir judiciaire et des
libertés publiques et celle là on va les
faire entrer dans le droit commun ne
seront plus exceptionnels comme c'est le
cas dans la droite dans l'état d'urgence
et ses restrictions peuvent être
utilisés pour des choses qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ça le rapport d'amnistié
internationale a clairement montré il ya
quelques semaines que les dispositions
de l'état d'urgence avait été utilisée
pour réprimer les mains pour interdire
ont réprimé les manifestations à toi un
tout autre objet que celui de la lutte
donc un gérard landi
sur place sur les champs elysées qu'il
est nécessaire c'est une nécessité
aujourd'hui de l'introduire doit quand
même se trouve mais qu'elle est quel est
le rapport entre les dispositions lui on
voir deux de retrait du pouvoir
judiciaire dans certains alors et est et
ce qui s'est passé hier
parce que j'ai effectivement entendu
comme vous gérard collomb qui utilisent
cette cet événement pour dire ah ça
justifie bien mais quel est le rapport
entre les deux
c'est justement ce qui est débattu
depuis un moment et ce qui est mis en
cause par toute une partie des
professions judiciaires qu'ils disent
mais dans des glissements sur ce pour
leur nom par contre si on veut ouvrir le
débat sur la manière dont on continue de
lutter contre les phénomènes de
radicalisation d'un certain nombre de
deux jeunes français et tout un tas
d'autres dispositions y compris
internationale de lutte contre le
terrorisme etc
oui les fichiers ne vous en faites quoi
par exemple ça fait des mois peut-être
pouvoir une ou deux années qu'on ne
cesse d'en parler depuis les attentats
des questionnements que justement sur ça
y est c'est étonnant mais ce qui manque
c'est que justement ces renseignements
doivent pouvoir être exploitées sur le
terrain il faut des moyens sur le
terrain il faut le renseignement une
chose est de l'accumuler et encore il
faut vérifier qu'on est les dispositions
les dispositifs pour le faire mais
ensuite comment l'exploiter quand on a
pas sur le terrain notamment dans dans
les dents dans les communes où vivent
des d'aider des jeunes qui sont fichés s
comment est-ce qu'on travaille pour
prévenir sa fesse alors les
renseignements michel en a parlé tout à
l'heure la task force qui a été créé à
l'elysée auprès d'emmanuel macro ne sera
plus chargé d'une simple mission de
coordination mais pourrait
éventuellement avoir un pouvoir de
décision ça veut dire que le pouvoir
appartient dray oui mais au jarret là je
pense qu'on est on est justement dans à
nouveau avec cette mesure dans une
dérive
plus globale c'est une dérive de
concentration extrême des pouvoirs c'est
julie autour autour du président de la
résidence ça n'est pas seulement
emmanuel macro c'est une dérive qui ne
cesse de s'amplifier et qui a été
beaucoup amplifié du temps que la
sarkozie du temps de françois hollande
et qui va malheureusement visiblement
continuer avec emmanuel macron ça pose
des problèmes démocratiques ça pose des
problèmes d'efficacité de l'action
gouvernementale
ça pose des problèmes parce que tout ça
conduit à concentrer énormément de gens
tout autour du président de la rép mais
c'est un problème et certains bien sûr
les mêmes nous disent il faut un travail
d'équipé il faut que le gouvernement
soit soudées etc
et puis au lieu de donner les moyens à
ce gouvernement pouvoirs de de bien
travailler et aux administrations de le
faire au service public de le faire au
parlement de contrôler tout cela est
bien on continue de concentrer de
conserver les mains du président henri
guaino c'est un gage d'efficacité quels
risques
le gage d'efficacité lisse trop mais
qu'on nous promet il faut nous le
démontre et là encore mais il ya
récemment
oui je pense qu'à concentrer trop de
pouvoir être aux décisions importantes
dans les mains d'un seul homme est en
vérité elles ne sont pas dans les mains
d'un seul homme elles sont dans les
mains aussi à côté de cet homme d'une
armée de conseillers de l'équipe
derrière
alors voilà donc il ya une hypertrophie
près de là de tout de tout l'appareil
d'état présidentielle au détriment des
des autres institutions du pays donc
c'est une évolution du régime qui
devient au tout plan extrêmement
problématique alors à propos de l'état
d'urgence inscrit dans la loi ordinaire
n'est pas laisser tout à l'heure mais
quelle finir sa phrase il voulais vous
dire que le premier ministre affi a
précisé ce matin que le juge judiciaire
aurait son mot à dire avant toute mesure
administrative donc celle de grès belle
nature et où est rassuré écouter compte
comme on va avoir la discussion sur le
pen se re parlementaire on va vérifier
cette chose à leur tour dans le prêt de
deux dates auraient alors on écoute sur
ce sujet ce que nous disait la semaine
dernière estime m le présidentielle du
sénat gérard larcher qui vous rejoins
nous faut c'est vous qui le rejoignent
est sûre sur la vigilance nécessaire
on sera attentif aux libertés vigilant
on sera vigilant parce que la limite ici
c'est la protection des libertés
individuelles et collectives mais en
même temps on ne méconnaît pas la
réalité du terrorisme
bien sûr la sécurité vous estimez que
effectivement le sénat a un rôle à jouer
particulier le sénat je peux je pense
que la lutte contre le terrorisme
effectivement non seulement ne doit pas
se traduire par le recul des libertés
publiques mais au contraire je pense que
la défense des libertés publiques et de
nos libertés démocratiques fondamentales
fait partie de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
parce que cette c'est à ces règles
démocratiques assez protection des
libertés que s'attaque le terrorisme et
c'est la spirale dans laquelle il veut
nous entraîner et on voit
malheureusement dans le monde
on le voit avec trump et avec d'autres
beaucoup de régimes cd à cette spirale
qui est une spirale dangereuse une
spirale liberticide une spirale
guerrière et on sait qu en état de
guerre les libertés sont toujours
menacés dont il ne faut pas mettre le
doigt là dedans ce qui fait la force de
la france
face à cela c'est justement qu'elle
tienne bon sur ses libertés publiques
fondamentales bien leur vous parlait
déjà reconnu il ya un instant il va se
rendre très prochainement à calais vous
savez ce qui
j'ai eu un drame en cinq mots conducteur
est mort dans un accident provoqué par
une manifestation de migrants un barrage
très précisément il à dire la réponse ne
peut pas être simplement la
multiplication de l'ouverture de centres
d'accueil vous le rejoignez sur ce point
écoute et malheureusement on voit bien
que le
le drame de calais se renouvelle comme
on pouvait le craindre mais c'est pas
seulement le drame on le voit il est ici
à calais avec la situation des réfugiés
et la mort tragique d'un atom et du
dizaine de camionnettes 1 hier soir mais
la nuit dernière je crois il ya eu
encore 126 noyer on à la leaf rage dans
bateau au large vers les mobiles
continuent d'ouvrir des centres
d'accueil comme le demande anne hidalgo
ou comme le dit gérard collomb ce n'est
pas la seule réponse possible on part je
rappelle que sur cette question il ya
évidemment le problème fondamental de ce
qu'on fait dans la région pour faire
cesser la guerre parce que à l'origine
de tout ce qui se passe il ya quand même
ce dramatique problème
or pour le moment la guerre la guerre
continue avec des conséquences sur le
territoire et ensuite il y à un autre
grand problème qui n'est pas du tout
résolu sur lequel qui a fait beaucoup de
débats et sur lequel on a mis maintenant
un peu l'été noir c'est qu'il n'y a
toujours pas de politique d'accueil
européenne et non seulement il n'y a pas
de politique d'accueil européenne
solidaire mais l'europe a fini par en
quelque sorte entériné les logiques
égoïste d'un certain nombre de pays et
donc évidemment ça aggrave
considérablement le problème
et enfin je pense que dans cette
situation moi je continue à penser que
les moyens d'accueil ne sont pas
suffisants vous donneriez à d'autres
problèmes aussi il y à propos de calais
toujours le problème qui n'est pas
résolu de la fermeture de la frontière
britannique parce que les endroits où se
concentrent ce type de caen sont les
endroits où les frontières sont fermées
et est donc je pense qu'il faut ré
ouvrir l'ensemble de ces débats il n'y a
pas de solution miracle est simple il me
mais il faut ré ouvrir l'ensemble de ces
il me reste peu de temps pour vous
parler du sénat et de l'avenir du sénat
et de votre groupe vous avez à peu près
18 sénateurs qui vont être qu'ils vont
remettre en jeu pas à peu près je leur
poste est ce que vous espérez est ce que
vous êtes sûr et certain de pouvoir
avoir le même nombre en septembre
prochain
non nous ne sommes pas sûr et certain
d'avoir le menu home il ya deux de nos
sénateurs qui ne sont pas renouvelables
dont qui eux seront
qui seront toujours là des 18 sont
renouvelables
il ya une série de ces sénateurs qui
sont menacés parce que les zélés la
vague d'élections intermédiaires à
changer la composition du corps
électoral
je pense que en tout cas nous
travaillons à cela que nous pouvons
conserver un groupe est censé pouvoir
conserver un gros oui nous pensons
pouvoir conserver vos travaillons à cela
on va regarder votre fauteuil
et alors vous avez regardé les choses
oui normalement je serai élu sénateur de
paris mais vous savez que les avant de
répondre avec certitude à ça il faut
déjà attendre le 30 juin puisque c'est
la date à laquelle les conseils
municipaux se réunissent dans tous les
départements concernés pour désigner les
grands les grands électeurs et donc
c'est après la désignation de ces grands
électeurs par les conseils municipaux
que va démarrer appelons à plein régime
il pourrait y avoir un groupe en marche
au sénat ils vous ont contacté ou non je
pense qu'ils connaissent la star il
suffisait de vous écouter depuis
quarante cinq minutes
non non ils n'ont rien à attendre mais
rien à attendre de nous mais par contre
nous serons des opposants farouches que
nous savons faire
mais toujours mais toujours constructif
et notre groupe continuera à faire
beaucoup de propositions
si le gouvernement dit qu'il peut y
avoir des bonnes idées partout faut
qu'ils nous écoutent d'avant constructif
comme un merci beaucoup merci michael
merci pour leur merci à vous a tous à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]